tom holland and zendaya take their
romance to nyc i just feel very lucky
here's the couple holding hands while
leaving a hotel together on wednesday
both looking stylish as ever the dune
star rocks a black oversized shirt dress
with a black belt tights and dark heels
while her bow sports a black turtleneck
and light gray suit with dress shoes
both stars coordinating their outfits
with black face masks zendaya is the one
at serving looks she is the one to go
for for tips
and lately the two have been spending
lots of quality time together because
earlier in the day z and t did a little
retail therapy the public outing follows
their trip to london last month where
the two paid a visit to tom's family
it's just the beginning of this really
adorable
romance that we're watching kind of
bloom on camera the love birds seem to
be enjoying some down time since the
december release of their film
spider-man no way home
some suggest that parker's powers
include the male spider's ability to
hypnotize females stop come on yes my
spider lord
but the hypnotizing goes both ways
remember this sweet moment at the
premiere
how are you feeling about that and
tackling that they're losing things i
think sunday just sounds like it just
showed up
[Applause]
of course hints of a romance between the
co-stars swirled around for years before
they confirmed their relationship it
happens all the time and of course you
know we we expected it i mean it's it's
um
it comes with the territory it comes
with the job
speculation really started heating up
last july when tom and zendaya were
spotted kissing in a car what is it like
to know that you broke the internet um
those pictures of you and tom and people
were so excited because they're like
spider-man mj it's real like it was like
the world was rooting for this moment
well i'm i'm excited for the film to
come out i can't wait for everybody to
see um spiderman when it does come out
and you know we we all work so hard
we're all so you know we're all so close
from that and um yeah i mean i i i'm
excited we're gonna have a good press
tour i think
jump to november and spider-man himself
officially declared himself taken during
a chat with gq
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there
so although their spiderman trilogy is
over fans are still wondering could we
see tom and zendaya together on screen
again i don't know how excited people
would be to just jump on board when et
caught up with the actress about season
two of euphoria she teased this
your boy tom holland said he would love
a cameo i mean what does he have to do
to show up for season three listen we
talked about it you know because uh um
he supported me through the whole the
whole season and you know we we joke
about like just spitting them into the
background
it was an easter egg see if someone can
can spot him spidey joining roo and the
gang we'd love to see it
till then we'll just keep marveling over
them as a couple
[Music]